omar says your performance in midnight
mass was outstanding sheriff hassan's
monologue on why he became a cop was one
of the most powerful and important
moments of tv i saw last year
so
yeah you obviously are having an impact
on people
it's it's um
i didn't expect i don't the worst kind
of
i've i've ever felt about a project and
a work i've done is is sheriff hassan
like i i thought i [ __ ] it and i
didn't speak to the cast during filming
i really the worst imposter robert
longstreet who was in that who i just
dear
he loves you i know you just had dinner
with him yeah yeah and he just says
you're so good you're so committed to
the role you're so
uh you didn't talk to us to the cast
during that no because you know what the
character was sort of like an outsider
yeah and it was covered we were the
first show back one of the first shows
to make a show during covid so i we were
already bubbling we were already
isolated i had the worst imposter
syndrome i think i've ever experienced
in my entire career
i
didn't feel like there was a safety net
for me um
mike
gave me enough so mike was good enough
that i never spiraled in a way that
we're capable of spiraling but i was
still on the [ __ ] edge yeah and
i've never experienced this before like
we'd finish a scene and i'd sit in my
trailer two hours i was crying head in
my hands i'm like i'm putting my worst
work
to screen and there's nothing i can do
you really thought it was your worst
i mean it like it's not like
it's not some flowery way to then be
like and then it came out no it was the
what mike knew it my everyone everyone
could feel it around me i didn't believe
in anything i was doing
and
you know i'm not muslim
i'm not american i'm not 40. i don't
have a kid i'm so out of my depths with
this character um
and then you never know it oh dude
worst i like i was considering
a complete social media blackout phone
uh marooning i was going to do it the
javascript oh crazy what goes through
your mind yeah you just like everything
was coming down on you but knowing
that you it's it wasn't real it's not
real it's all in your head i guess
i guess i mean mike knew might know that
and like
i remember in somewhere like the show
came out in september and and
september yeah and uh around about june
or something mike
we were doing something for netflix and
he was like you want to come watch it
it's great you're great come watch it
and i'll say
and you loved it no
you didn't no i thought i i remember
walking away going
you didn't break the show
which is a very arrogant thinking is
like we're so conceited we think that
our contribution we're going to make her
break it yeah we suck the show's done no
exactly so that's when my biggest fear
was you got hamish link later and kate
siegel and and sam sloin doing these
incredible performances
and you think you're gonna break the
show that's that's the attitude i had
and then i watched it and i walked away
going it's [ __ ] phenomenal despite
the crap you committed
you